не галоген проект куща новий
кабінету міністрів України деки харчування
у ступу до вищих початкових закрити його
крайових категорій громадян
передача я за забезпечення dota таких
соціальних гарантій
кошторис та посил та не соціальної захисту
учасники в антитерористичній
операції в донецьку та луганську та області
акта що не в їх сімей цем актон
передача потреб убиті бачка про дим із бочки
столітті їх заглянув і печатать участь у
антитерористичної операції захищаю
чини за лісовик суверенітет і
територіальну цілісність України обидва
померли в нас йдуть пурани не культурі та
чика листя
получених у районах проводу менти
туристичні по рації zara
вищих початкових закладів
на місці а державної сама flannel major
op сидить державного замутнення на
підготовку у фіктивного підступного cocada
логічних тару бітних кадрів на первинний
кваліфікації та перепідготовку кадру в
2016 уроки зад virgin їх адже по видну
постанову та кабінету міністрів
прийняття проекту актом на потребу і ви
справи до готових коштів державного
бюджету України
прошу Петро і мати